clear something up for me last time you
were here
you said to me
hey you know i'm here in new york i'm
going to get in touch with sarah jessica
parker i'm going to take her to lunch
remember that yes and you you even
called very nicely called matthew
broderick and said look man can i if i'm
being an [ __ ] you tell me but i
really i went out with sarah for years i
just want to say hi i want to go take
her to lunch and he gave you the green
light to take her to lunch did you do it
really it wasn't
required
right it's not like some possessive
thing and you know how life goes and so
many things happen and particularly when
you're looking at the back nine you're
not a kid anymore you go you know this
trip to new york as opposed to just
doing what's required of me i actually
want to take care of some personal
business i want to
check in with someone i shared a big
part of my life with and say hi you were
in love with her absolutely did it
happen did you make amends or something
to her um well i mean
private stuff aside we were able to
spend some time together and it was it
was really cool where'd you go um i went
over to her place and then we went down
uh the street i actually drove by this
place like some tapas place on the
corner with a friend of hers after
and you know the funny thing too is you
always have a perception of somebody
that you spend a big chunk of your life
with and
and um and i think it's typical it's a
human thing to the further you get away
from that your new new relationship
you you you sub-intentionally taint your
perception of the person and then seeing
her i was like she is so
great and so cool and so funny and so in
command and i got to
meet her kids and i saw the way she and
matthew lived and i respect both of them
so much and i was like man it's just
it's so weird how but you couldn't say
the things you wanted to say to her i
said everything i want to say really yes
even with the friend sitting there no he
wasn't there until we went to dinner
oh so you got everything off your chest
that's right you said hey you know i
know things got [ __ ] up between us and
blah blah blah blah just making me happy
to see you how are you one of those kind
of things right absolutely where you
appear to be
very uh self-realized and a different
kind of guy you know what i'm not so
good at that because i'm nowhere near as
evolved as i think i am
it happens in a kind of haphazard way
and it's a little bit stilted but then
you just there's this familiarity that
that overtakes it and you realize you're
just in the presence of this fully
mature mother and woman and artist and
human being and and and there's enough
good will left over you didn't burn that
bridge where you can say hey you know
was it so emotional that you were crying
no sir not too bad you have fresh eyes
and you're actually willing to go to a
deeper level of acceptance and and kind
of just make peace with the way life is
any time i was in a relationship i
thought you're going to bury me next to
this woman right and it's not that
simple and god has other plans